She's a,
if you take the interesting about ultra marathons is like we kind of,
we're small enough sport where it's like you can't really say like,
Oh,
I'm a hundred miler.
It's like,
okay.
You know?
It's like,
yeah,
I know.
So like you have everything from a 50 kilometer that's got over 10,000 feet of
climbing and descending to a six day event on a track and they're all the same
sport.
When you look at like people who can kind of do really well at all of them,
or in Courtney's case really well at all of them,
you can't find a better female on the female side of things.
Someone who can do it better than that.
Like she does it.
She goes,
it goes on the track,
kills it.
She goes and 240 miles through the mountains kills it.
It's,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
She's something on really,
really unusual.
You know,
a buddy of mine,
my friend Brian,
it was texting me about her while she was getting Brian is he doesn't even run,
I don't think are barely,
I mean it's not a,
but he was just so fascinated by this one woman that was so far ahead of
everybody just like what the fuck is she doing?
Then she beat the second place guy by 10 hours in a 238 mile race,
22 miles.
She was ahead of him.
Yeah.
That's an interesting topic to where like the where like men and women in an
ultra marathon and how that kind of like where it's one of the rare races where
women can win and it's the,
the interesting thing to me about it is women can and do win some races,
but when they're like,
like Courtney's very much the most,
I would say talented person to do one of the 200 milers.
Yet like there hasn't been a lot of what like the,
the top of the sport hasn't really moved into that.
I mean Courtney certainly is top of the sport,
but she's thinks she's the best.
I think she's the best woman all around.
Right.
If certainly in the United States thinks she's the best at running those 200
milers.
Uh,
is it dependent upon altitude gain and loss and,
and just variables to the day?
I think like,
so like,
I mean there's,
there's some real,
like there's a guy named Kilian journey,
um,
and he spells his name J.
O.
R.
N,
e t and uh,
he won the,
um,
or he,
he's,
he's essentially the best mountain runner by far.
Like there's maybe one of the guy who could maybe compete with him at something
under a hundred miles,
but if it's like he's,
he's,
he would probably like beat everyone by who knows how much in a 200 we've seen
one of these videos before.
Yeah.
He'll,
he'll run on these,
he'll run on these like ridge lines and like,
it will be the death on both sides.
And he just
play,
this
is fucking guys,
man.
So,
oh,
I have CMS isn't even nearly a chance of them.
Oh,
Mike.
Yeah,
that's,
that's crazy.
Look at them.
It looks like a freak to the GoPro strapped to his heaven.
That's got to throw your balance off.
He's running with a Gopro.
Put that down intention.
That was my son.
I'd be like,
pay attention where you're running kid Jesus.
He's interesting because I mean his parents were like mountaineers I think and
like so he was like basically playing in the mountains at like age three and
basically grew up doing this stuff.
So God,
yeah,
he's the,
he's the type of guy who like,
he's,
he's probably the best in the sport right now and it's
all my guys jumping around.
He's an asshole.
He's,
he is running folks.
What is this a video?
Instagram.
I don't really know.
Okay.
[inaudible] spell his name.
Kay.
I is that two L's one L I a n j.
O r n e.
T.
And he's running in Shumway.
How do you say that?
Chamonix [inaudible] France and he's running one on what looks like the fin of a
shark.
If a shark was the size of a mountain,
this guy's a fucking animal,
man.
That is so scary.
Oh,
interesting.
Sweaty.
My hands are sweating,
scared,
just watching it.
And so he is the best.
Yeah,
on the mountains for sure.
He doesn't do anything that's not mountainous.
Like he did Western states and won it in 2011 and he was complaining about it
being too flat.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What is the gain and loss of elevation in Western saying net downhill.
So it's 2100 or 23,000 feet down.
17,000 feet up.
What?
So
he's complaining about that.
Yeah,
it's too flat.
[inaudible] 17,000 feet up
and it gets much crazier.
And that you can do,
you can do like 50 miles or a hundred k's that have the same profile as that.
So you can get like if you're doing like what he's doing,
that probably does feel kind of flat for him.
Like he likes that steep technical stuff.
So,
but yeah,
so as far as the mountains go,
he's the,
he's the guy to beat for sure.
And he'll do races on a regular basis when he is running,
cause he's actually a professional skier too.
So like he's only running basically half of the year and he's skiing.
The other half is Christ.
So He's,
he's a fun dude to follow for sure.
Um,
but yeah,
it's a w when you look at like some of the races that are kind of the big races,
like Western states,
100 is the most competitive hundred miler in the United States and ultra trail
Mont Blanc,
which is actually by Chamonix where you saw that video is probably at least last
year was the most competitive in the world.
Um,
those are the reasons I like to look at.
I kind of see like where the divergences from the males and the females.
Uh,
and if you look at like course records and winning times,
like,
you know,
the men are finishing like two plus hours ahead of the women are on a pretty
regular basis on that type of stuff.
And,
um,
at ultra trail mount blonde,
you know,
sometimes it's four or five hours,
uh,
and then it,
so then you can kind of lay,
it actually kind of is more in line with what you see with other endurance
distances,
like marathons and stuff like that.
Uh,
the crazy thing about it though is,
uh,
that doesn't mean that's going to happen every time.
Like there's certainly years where women do really well and finish like in the
top 10 amongst the in like,
look Western states or Utm B..